journalism is under attack like never
before no husband between tear gas fire
you have to have the fans beautiful but
tragic because people are doubting
everything you're the only way of
telling their story how would you
describe this outbreak something like an
apocalypse you're going to be really
tired you're going to be really scared
it's too dangerous anyone who says
they're not scared is lying
anything can happen
did you get here i sometimes wonder how
have we managed to get out of
this we do genuinely believe in what we
do he's clearly march's press to show
the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover an injustice
this is the result of ethnic cleansing i
don't think any journalist wants
anything more than that i'm alex
crawford i'm stuart ramsey and this is
hot spots
good morning you're watching a special
dedicated channel for the un climate
change summit cop26
this was the biggest climate change
conference with all the global leaders
going to be in one city if we don't get
serious about climate change today it
will be too late for our children
tomorrow we say no more blah blah blah
last best chance to save the earth no
more exploitation of the planet but
if you're going to try to illustrate
climate changes that are taking place
you do have to go to some of the places
in the world where it's obvious that
it's being affected
our editors drew up a sort of map of the
world and they basically
sent a huge number of deployments
everywhere to try to highlight this
issue this is one of the countries that
is most vulnerable here in brazil where
the deforestation pledge could have an
impact this is a city that will become
uninhabitable with so much oil gas and
coal still to extract for decades to
come here it is probably already too
late
stuart and i talked beforehand about
where we should be he was going to be in
brazil
the amazon is uh described as the luns
of the earth and it's the trees are
being cut down and it has huge numbers
of fires
both thought you know i should be trying
to get to madagascar it's crops are
being eaten by these
plagues of locusts it has tremendous
cyclones and floods and droughts
it is climate change all in one
i think what we were most worried about
is that trying to make it interesting
enough because what you want as a
journalist is to grab the public by the
neck and make them make them watch you
[Music]
[Music]
brazil is in many ways at the center of
the climate story it's at the center of
the story because at the amazon
rainforest you know vast majority of the
forest is in brazil
and is under threat
it's also politically a very hot topic
in brazil because of the president uh
president bolsonaro who is a climate
denier i'd never been to brazil before
so i went with a fairly open mind really
hoping to go there and just find
something that might sort of
get to the person watching it you know
have an impact that might make them
care i suppose what's in the green bag
oh it's a first aid kit
a big one we don't usually travel with
such big ones but because we're in the
amazon and there's no real access to
medical care we've got a big one
let's hope we don't need to use it for
anything
when i made contact with yvonne an
amazon
expert and our local producer there i
said
you know we want to come and drive the
br163 and do the story on deforestation
[Music]
the r163 is the highway that goes right
through swathe of land of the amazon
right through the jungle it's about two
thousand kilometers but a significant
amount of the traffic on that road is
illegal illegal logs illegal cattle
movement
and our job was to go and try and see
what this road was like
and also to sort of see the effects it
had
a lot of the production in this area is
legal
but a great deal of the production in
this area is also illegal and that means
there's a real skepticism not just the
skepticism but a hatred really of
journalists for starters and so
a number of times you know when we
wanted to stop along the br 163 to film
deforestation or at one point we stopped
to film palm oil trees being cut down
there is a tension
there seems to be this sense that people
are talking to one another and certainly
you get the sense that even from this
distance
we were spotted and they stopped and
sent someone down to look so i think
we're probably moving on
more environmental journalists have been
killed in brazil than anywhere else in
the world um environmental activists are
murdered regularly so it is a dangerous
land because
it's worth a huge amount of money
we pulled off the road at one bit of the
br 163 and it was kind of tree-lined and
then suddenly it just opened up into
wide space and we pulled off to go and
see what it was and
what we found was what i'd pretty much
describe as a as a tree graveyard
you know talk about tipping
i'd say here the tipping point is passed
it's gone it can't recover from this
just
hundreds of trees chopped down and burnt
including like really magnificent old
huge trees
what do you think
it's unbelievable
it really is
i mean it's not exactly done in secret
is it
to see it on such a wide scale and not
only that but not deep in the forest
just right there on the side of the road
you know as if
to say well we don't care no one's
watching anyway or there's no
accountability
well that's a samara tree it's a very
inside three on the amazon and it's
extremely important for the indigenous
because it collects water and also it's
used for communicate so it's like it's
like a drum you see
so if you are in a closed forest
and then they can hear it from the tribe
really far away i mean i don't it's
really an old tree it's going to end up
in a firewood or in a furniture
somewhere it's a shame
[Music]
it's not paradise lost it's a paradise
stolen and it's been
completely
selfishly just stripped
i was hard to believe we're actually in
the middle the heart of the amazon
rainforest
all you can see is a
farmland
you can see a lot of devastation but
there's also a lot going on that you
can't see
these huge trucks appear with these
massive ancient trees that they've cut
down from somewhere deep in the forest
so we were driving along the road and
saw a massive truck come with huge logs
on board
um and so we drove up the road uh that
it had come out of and we're now at a
logging camp which is like really
difficult to get into as a rule but for
some reason they're being quite friendly
as he was walking away
the guy who's with him who's been very
helpful as well
was just laughing to himself
it's like yeah they're really going to
give you a permit
we will try once again and hopefully we
will end up with a permit i'm not sure
but we'll try
most of the time how people stopped you
doing stuff there was to hit you with
delays
so he's obviously going to go in and see
um if the loggers allow us to film yes
of course you may film there's no
problem you need to drive six hours down
the road get the paperwork get it signed
and come back
because they know you're not going to do
that very jumpy all the time
they just changed their mind they don't
want us to get in
it's never smooth in the amazon
i mean they could overreact our
situation in here so i'm gonna do it
from safe side
driving along this road actually the
communities who live on it you you can
see are poor
they don't have much and they used to
have the rainforest you know we met joao
in his house is there a steward he's
lived where he's lived his whole life he
was born there and he described us how
when he was growing up there wasn't even
a road
grant
it's difficult to
swing by drive up the road say hi can we
chat to you hear somebody's story and
say well thanks very much and be on your
way
you can't really not think about what
ifs what if this road wasn't built
well it was promised that the trucks and
the traffic of the 163 were going to
bring huge wealth to these communities
and in fact
they've actually bought poverty this was
an extremely wealthy community and it
was able to grow fruit and vegetables
and exist from the rainforest now that's
what's left of the rainforest it's still
very beautiful but it's a tiny clump all
of this area was rainforest
[Music]
nothing happens without your fixer
yvonne was a very good fixer
i mean when we filmed the stuff with the
cows
that didn't happen without him
well i i don't know what he said i mean
why would they even let us in there with
the camera what they're doing is illegal
[Applause]
so yvonne had gone down to the port and
met the man who was kind of in charge of
the movement of cattle that were coming
from the ranches to be exported out to
the wider world and explained that we're
doing a story about um yeah about the
production chain of of cattle farming in
in the amazon rainforest and he said
okay you can film how we load cattle
so we knew the cows were going to come
down the cattle run to the back of the
boat
so i'd set up various things
and i hadn't really considered the fact
that what would happen happened
the last cow that came up the ramp sort
of stumbled over
part of that ramp and collapsed
then kept slipping and sliding it just
got weaker and weaker and weaker
in the
hours that followed you know they tried
absolutely everything to try and get the
cow to move
you remember a lot of these steer are
often genetically engineered so they
they're actually really heavy they're
they're not particularly good at moving
the best of times
pulling its tail they were trying to
drown it so that it would get angry and
then get up and go
kicking it in the face
i mean the footage speaks for itself
[ __ ] horrible yeah
no i might be a vegetarian again after
the reason why it's barbaric and this
ultimately goes to the root of the story
those
steer are not legal
they have been raised on farms that
aren't legal
and they're being sold
and will slowly become legitimate
through illegal methods
they're worth an awful lot of money
if the hundred steer are supposed to get
on that boat
100 have to get off dead or alive
put this away none of us had a stake
that night
um
yeah i had quite a profound effect on me
that section actually
[Music]
it was a real wake-up call for me about
awareness
do you know where your food comes from
because the fact is that that cow that
they export from there to europe
i don't think people really understand
the
results of having a nice beef on the
table
it's was like a really tough time to
watch it's horrible
as the hours went by more and more
people were sort of looking at us
looking at the car looking at us look in
the car like getting all stressed out
which was happening that's a guy just
came up and said you not to report on
this
um whole thing
the uh the guys who load the cattle here
that's just life to them they don't care
but somebody from the outside world as
it were knows that that could cause all
sorts of eruptions i suspect it probably
will actually because it's pretty brutal
unregulated there's no vets
no food no water that animal i cannot
see how it's going to survive an
overnight boat trip and then four days
in a truck no way
when we started getting threats from the
ranching community saying
you can't show that it makes the whole
beef industry in brazil look bad and
then the messages started getting a bit
more you know your life will be in
danger if you show it
just like i want to share the situation
with you guys i just received a message
unfortunately they want us to pretend
that we haven't seen that situation we
haven't seen like all the violence
against the castle
so actually i think he wants to to
somehow us to fix it and delete the
footage yeah if someone says you can't
film something then that's probably
in your mind that's something that needs
a picture taking of it so they were
starting to track who we are and what we
are doing and make a lot of questions it
could be like a sort of risky situation
that we should be aware of it
trouble with the ranchers and the uh and
in fact the loggers they have a history
of being quite violent to people who say
things about that they don't like and
that's why so many environmentalists end
up in a lot of trouble right yeah i
suppose the kind of censorship with um
with a gun
so somebody who said don't show this
well you know i'm not i am going to show
it because we weren't there it wasn't
hidden they knew we were there we'd been
there all day there was nothing to hide
about it but you can tell us why you
think it's not representative of what
happens and all the rest of it
[Music]
with a foreboding experience driving
into nova progresso surrounded by this
intense electrical storm knowing that
there are lots of people there who would
really not want to see us
we did have to take the threat seriously
we talked about it as a team
we did note that we needed to change our
route
it was very easy in these situations to
get extremely paranoid and do things
like fleeing in the middle of the night
we didn't want to overreact so we
decided that we would leave nova
progresso and we headed in a completely
different direction to the one we had
planned
everyone just felt it's not wise to fly
out the same way we flew in um our guys
here think that we might have problems
with one of the farmers it's a very
small airport in santoram so now we're
going south and we're actually in
another state now so we're fully quite
relaxed we're in mata grosso
so we've done two pieces both in brazil
but cop still has a week to run
i get a call from the news desk to say
oh um so do you think maybe you can go
to peru next um you know the world's
highest tropical glacier is there oh my
i'm sorry what glacier we're in the
rainforest i was very excited because
i've never been to peru
i've been to the andes and i love the
andes so
on a strictly personal i was quite
excited
[Music]
so we flew into lima from brazil
we then drove all the way towards the
caldera blanca mountain range in the
andes
i've never been to peru before new
country
none of us have been to peru before
first time in peru and first time in
peru and
coming as yoda
i hate these glasses
and we're going other places hopefully
if we can deal with the
traumatization which is actually quite a
big thing because it's really really
high it's like
almost ever a space campfire
it doesn't matter how fit you are it
does just some people get affected by it
and really badly and some people not so
badly first thing is headaches but i
mean you can get to a later point where
actually
you you die really quite quickly you
know you're supposed to stop
on your journey up let your system get
used to being at altitude and keep
moving up and keep moving we didn't have
time to do that
we sat down with charlie our mountain
guide who we'd met who was going to take
us up to the glaciers
and we started to work out what was
actually possible in the time that we
had
the plan today traps
is we'll depart from the lodge here
our two transport four by fours will
drive up the yangan uncle gorge and
arrive at four thousand six hundred
meters they just switch back here
trek
on a contouring line around the mountain
and
we should make it there by about midday
now i'm even walking up here to come to
breakfast i was out of breath so yeah
fingers crossed confident toby yeah
actually
rather excited
i had no concept of what i was getting
myself into it
transpires the walk to the glacier was
just
probably the most physically difficult
thing i've done in years
my legs felt like logs
you know i'm uh would consider myself a
relatively fit person and i do a lot of
walking generally but this was just on a
whole nother level
i remember thinking well you know stu is
a little old to me maybe i should keep
an eye on stuart stewart's like a
machine
what
yeah that's not where i'm walking i mean
stuart powered through it
yeah i was like oh okay then so we all
we all felt like we better keep up
you brought cash right
lovely little pub up there
[Music]
physically climbing up glaciers is a
pretty long way once upon a time you
just failed to drive to glacier get out
of the car and say oh look there's the
glacier now it's retreated so far that
it's um really quite a long trek
that's incredible
wasn't it 433
you can see that almost like polish rock
slab is a very different tone and below
you can see the little golden grass and
the rocks when i was here
17 years ago or maybe even 15 years ago
there's maybe one waterfall coming off
that glacier that has receded all the
way back so a couple of hundred meters
and when i was actually up here in
november a couple of years ago there
were nine waterfalls coming off it it
melted before your eyes i mean it's it's
i was crying i was filming a clip and
just crying
he was showing how quickly you know
areas that we were walking on were
impossible to have walked upon a few
years before because it would have just
been you know 15 foot of ice that is now
just grass
climate change and increasing
temperatures hit this part of the world
in the 1970s glaciers started melting
that wasn't a disaster because huge
amounts of water was released went down
the valleys and went eventually all the
way to the deserts near the coast where
there was a farming bonanza because of
the huge amount of water that was
created
very soon perhaps in the next two
decades there won't be any water and
those farms will all be in desert once
again these glaciers have been there for
thousands of years and the water's just
pouring off them
there's kind of
silence around our team as toby filmed
and i remember just looking at that lazy
and just going
wow
i just want to let you know we're okay
um we haven't had any signal or even sat
phone signal until right now
thanks laura bye
you've seen what you're sitting in front
of
that's amazing
that might be the best phone call
location ever i think it is
imagine from brazil
even more friends than we are we brought
our amazon expert to the andes it's not
going well
yeah it's not the place for amazon
van was keen to come and i think we were
we were quite keen to have him along as
well
i would have to say this
he was a bit knackered going up the
mountain
i know it was a challenge for him but he
said he absolutely loved it so at least
there was that well with the strong team
support you can do everything
it's great i mean it's like for me
unique experience to have a brazilian
from the amazon up to the glaciers it's
unique
well done oh guys
my head is bagging
what we wanted our story to do would be
to connect this part of the world to
what was going on in glasgow we wanted
people to see where we were and to
realize that it's not about some far
away country or that individual
countries are not the ones who have to
solve their own problems this is all of
our problem and that was the theme at
glasgow how people can come together and
solve it standing on that glacier you
couldn't have felt further away from the
heart of the problem but actually you
were kind of standing on the problem
[Music]
up next
this is a fragile win as the fate of the
planet lies in the hands of world
leaders at the cot climate conference it
was deemed to have been a success
because it wasn't an abject failure i'm
in madagascar a country on the brink of
the world's first climate famine
i don't think it felt much like a
success to the people who were digging
for water in a dry riverbed
madagascar is situated in the indian
ocean
it is one of the world's largest islands
it's about twice the size of britain
to us madagascar was the perfect example
of what can happen to a country
purely because of climate change or to a
large extent because of climate extremes
it's a country that's almost buried in
these tropical sands its crops are being
eaten by these
plagues of locusts it has tremendous
cyclones and floods and droughts the
united nations is calling it a first
country that was on the brink of famine
caused by climate change
[Music]
getting in there was
very very difficult not least because of
the chronovirus pandemic it had shut
itself out to the rest of the world
and the government basically
had decided it didn't want outsiders in
a lot of sleepless nights for chris
trying to work out how to get in i
really didn't think um he'd be able to
do it this is the one that we want oh
yes
welcome to madagascar beautiful it
wasn't easy um i yeah i deluxed quite a
few gray hairs on this one
but we're here
somehow it worked it was totally worth
it but for those
weeks before we left it was the bane of
my life
the only time i actually believed we
were going to get into madagascar was
when we touched down and even then i
thought we're going to get turned back
been hit hard with david
they were
happy to be welcoming um
you know a bunch of tourists and
business people
it became obvious almost straight away
how poor people were
[Music]
people were living in conditions that
you would say dated back to the to the
middle ages
[Music]
look at the state of this road we can't
really call it a road this is not a road
it's just a cut in the middle of a
forest
pretty bumpy
terrible terrible infrastructure they're
just hole after hole after hole after
hole which obviously adds to the
the poverty and the difficulties because
it's very difficult to get from from
place to place
we turned up at this unicef feeding
station basically
they were trying to encourage
mothers with babies or toddlers to come
and get some nutrition they would get
some some food and
water
everywhere you looked there were
children with
orange tinged hair which was a sign of
chronic malnutrition
[Music]
[Applause]
all had these big swollen
bellies hundreds and hundreds of mothers
and children
all
they're all
in pretty desperate and dire conditions
uh and they had walked you know
probably 10 12 20 kilometers to get
there on that day so that they could
just have at least something to eat the
people of madagascar have long been used
to carry the drought that brings hunger
but this is probably the worst in 40
years and everyone that we're seeing
here is showing signs of
undernourishment or starvation we were
shown into one area of the the compound
to where
some children were ill and
being treated
[Music]
we saw this young girl who barely had
the energy to cry
i'm monitoring this so they know she's
not in a good place
the babies in the hospital were
were really
well knocking on knocking on on heaven's
door really
i think the doctors the nurses they're
basically just trying to ease them
through their their last few days and
weeks
seeing small
little babies like that who have no
chance is i mean that's
that's that's that's always
always going to be
upsetting
now this was my first time
seeing
i guess the impact of
hunger
on
on such a large scale um
and it was yeah it was it was
i mean
there's just
you feel
helpless you feel sad you feel angry
um
yeah it was it was tough
some parts of the south haven't had
proper rainfall in a decade
it was a huge enormous
long journey to get down to the south
and we did part of it by plane
and as soon as we started hitting the
road you could see
a dry river bed after dry riverbed
we stopped at one dry river crossing you
can see on the drone just how far into
the distance this river snakes and
how they're forced to basically just dig
holes to get down to the water table and
they're using that for one for washing
for drinking cleaning and cooking
the dry season isn't due to start for
another three months this is meant to be
the rainy season and they haven't had
significant rainfall for many years
to us it exemplified all the problems of
what a drought can do it can suck up all
the water from a riverbed and all these
people were coming from miles and miles
around
just to try and desperately dig
into this sandy bed
they're struggling and the farmers just
cannot do their job they can't they
cannot farm they struggle to to grow
crops
so we set out to try and find some of
the the more remote villages and
communities we would you know obviously
driving through these vast expanses of
nothing of cactuses
and baobabs
there's no roads
there's no road signs
you basically
navigate using the stars to get to to
these places but
our local
malagasy people saying they'd heard this
community was was suffering quite a lot
so we headed out there we we stopped
actually to just film some general shots
of the landscape
we noticed some farmers just walking
across the field
we
initially tried to talk to them
they're they're afraid of me apparently
not the first people who'd been afraid
of me wouldn't don't want to talk to me
they reacted with a lot of suspicion
our drivers our guides tried to
negotiate with them to say look we're
just filming there's no problem here
they were desperate people who saw us as
rich foreigners and therefore
able to help them out
they asked for money
what's what's happening amen they need
money they want why do they want money
they'll be open to talk when they get
some money
they wanted to be paid to be filmed
i felt that was probably the wrong way
to go because
you know we don't pay people for
interviews or for filming because that's
can lead people to
be dishonest
okay
we turn turn them down and then they
barricaded the
the the road
and wouldn't let us through i mean
they're basically holding us
to ransom it was
just the one road we knew led to the
village they had machetes they had
sticks with knives on they had all sorts
they're saying we can't go on now
is that what they're saying
these were
not much more than kids what they were
doing was just born out of desperation
it's a very difficult
moral conundrum because
you really don't want to give in to
something like that
the drivers i think were thinking we
want to avoid conflict they do not want
violence they do not want us to be
attacked
so the drivers kind of like pacified
them
and we set on our way
you know
[Music]
level of litigation but they were very
worried about what was going to happen
on the way back because they they
thought they were going to be waiting
for us on the way back
in the village
there they were obviously suffering
there were an awful lot of children and
bulk of them had these huge huge bellies
and they were
eating
cactus flowers
cactus flowers which they knew were
probably going to make them sick but
they didn't have
any alternative
this is their dinner
and this is all they'll eat today
they looked a lot older than they
actually were you know they weren't
healthy
and how do you feel about eating these
cactuses
one in two
kids
under five
suffer from chronic malnutrition and
stunting because they don't have enough
food and nutrition to live
it was
a really sad sight
since the drought started there'd been
this incredible rise in banditry and
people stealing crops and people
stealing food stuff and people
desperation breeds crime
so when we so when we left the village
elder and his sort of right hand man
came with us
sure enough as we came to the spot
where we'd been held up before
there were these boys still there
waiting hiding knives in their jackets
and the village elder and his um
his right-hand man got out and
really started tearing into them telling
them how how badly behaved they were and
how this was not on
had he not come along we would have had
to confront them again we didn't need to
be held up again
[Music]
madagascar
should be one of the richest countries
in the world based on its natural
resources instead it's one of the
poorest
everywhere you look 360 there's an
environmental issue
illegal mining is they reckon the second
biggest
employer in the whole of of the country
it's on a big scale
and they're doing it all over the place
this whole area used to be covered with
trees you can see they've all been
cut off now
and replaced by a huge
mining community
these are sort of
old school gold rushes where one lucky
team will go to one area and have one
lucky fight
the gems are hidden many many meters
below
and they're doing this
because they've been driven to it by
poverty they think if they find just one
sapphire just one
bit of barrel or one ruby
their lives will be transformed
there's this big black market economy
this huge number of of poor people
operating in
really really dangerous pitiful
conditions
these holes are everywhere it's actually
quite dangerous with walking around
you've got to look down at where you're
walking because
they're literally mine shafts just
everywhere
it would have been
deadly to walk around at night uh just
because you could literally fall down 80
meters and kill yourself
tipping down there
all of them have this dream that
they'll be the ones that find the jewel
the gem that will pull them out of
poverty
whoa okay how deep is that one
come on have a look at this kev
stop it
back in my mind i was thinking it would
be quite an experience to go down that
that shaft
alex was considering going down yeah i
was encouraging her actually but she she
was advised not to by our
our team the rest of our team so we gave
a small camera to one of the miners who
who
allowed us onto his area and he filmed
for us down the hall
is a
very long way down very long way down it
took about two minutes
from top
to bottom and then when he got down
there's this tiny hole which he crawled
through
whilst he was down there we're up top
talking to the guys who were busy
fanning air down the their makeshift
plastic tube just delivering air to them
and whilst in the middle of all of this
the bag breaks
what's happened is it broken yeah it's
broken oh where is it where is it broken
can you show us
oh it's torn all the way down the side
alley's down there and he's running out
of air
they sort of try and stick it together
with cellotape
in what seemed like an agonizingly long
time
i don't feel they're going fast enough
after five minutes or so they managed to
take the bag up and start pumping air
down again
i mean the bag didn't look that
sufficient to be honest
after that i think there was a very
definite mood amongst the team that i
don't go down there
the gem buyers are something else
whole families are involved in spending
day after day after day after day trying
to get trying to get their gems
and they've got they come out eagerly
with their handful of
of gems that they hope they can sell
um and the gem buyers like
yeah not not good quality pretty rubbish
actually so omar what do you think of
the quality
and offers them some derisi amount
they've taken months to come up with
this and he's saying
not really worth anything and absolutely
crushes them
there's a very small number of malagasy
who are benefiting from the country's
natural resources and yet the huge
swathes of
their environment is being
ruined
absolutely ruined by legal and illegal
mining
it's a tough
tough world out there
[Music]
deforestation is a massive issue i think
most
environmental organizations and agencies
agree
that a huge bulk of their primary forest
may be up to as much as 90 percent of
madagascar's forests have disappeared as
a result of deforestation
is it to clear the trees we saw a lot of
slashing and burning on hills and fields
by the side of the road they're burning
huge suedes of land sometimes it's trees
parts of forest just
vegetation like this to try and clear
the area to prepare the land that they
can try and grow crops the sash and burn
was pretty mind-blowing it's having an
absolutely catastrophic impact
there's logging on
small medium and large scale people are
reliant on
wood unfortunately because they use it
for cooking for keeping themselves warm
as a livelihood it's a vicious vicious
circle
we were guided in in the forests uh by
christian and his team
he was a bit of a character he he was an
infectious sort of
quality to him he really you know has a
love for what happens there and his
knowledge is second to none
the forest guardians
stood out as
really really special people
they lived they breathed they worked
even though they were incredibly small
in number
they took us on this trek
through the forest
you know everywhere they go they're
spotting oh yeah this is um
a 2000 year old species and oh look at
this tiny little chameleon that is a
worldly more cryful good morning
communicate directly with us
that's what they're saying yes
he can speak lima language
i think we all loved it and the big draw
was the lima oh my goodness it was
amazing because i'd never seen one
before just practicing jumping yes
beginning learning one of the guides had
a
recording of lima's screeching
[Music]
this cacophony of noise and these these
lemurs all around us just screaming at
the top of their lungs and it was it was
just simply quite extraordinary
[Music]
i sort of looked around and everybody in
our group just had this incredibly huge
smile on their face
that
[Music]
i think for someone like kev and
cameraman it was like jackpot time
it was incredible and it's just you know
what an experience to film that
it was life defining stuff right now
the lemurs survive on these trees if
these trees disappear the lemurs
disappear
and you can only find these lemurs and
there are over 100 different species of
them here in madagascar in the wild and
they are the most
endangered
animals in the world at the moment
if everything carries on on the same
trajectory these animals are going to be
wiped out in a few years time there
won't be any of them left
[Music]
climate changes
is really crippling and affecting these
very very vulnerable poor countries like
madagascar now it's not happening
tomorrow it's not going to happen 10
years down the line it's happening now
the country
generates very little pollution
you know these people have very little
to do with the problem but
the ones that are suffering the most
that's all being done by the far far
richer countries many thousands of miles
away i think the 26th climate change
conference
they tried to make it out like it was a
success i don't think it felt much like
a success to the people underneath the
ground in those illegal mines in
madagascar or who are digging for water
in the middle of a dry riverbed
it is so decided
it was deemed to have been a success
because it wasn't an abject failure i
think that's probably the point let us
be clear
we do not need to face down but to face
out coal and fossil fuel subsidies one
didn't get a sort of sense of imminent
change for the good european wealth was
built on coal
and if we don't get rid of coal
european death will also be built on
call i think the the most vulnerable
countries feel like they're continually
going with a begging bowl to the richer
countries
felt angry this time really really angry
on behalf of the marshall islands i wish
to read into the record
our profound
disappointment the effect of
climate change and the effect of human
kinds
abuse of the planet is now absolutely
clear to everyone this year we've seen
the incredible fires across a range of
different countries we've seen the
flooding we've seen the glaciers melting
we've seen the droughts and now we're
seeing climate induced famine so i think
people heard it it's just whether
they're going to actually act on it now
we've moved beyond if we don't change
this will happen to
this has happened
what are we going to do
[Music]
they gave you
as cold as
i ice we lived
[Applause]